Ant-Man and the WASP the hero's journey
now available on Spotify as an audiobook
solidifies that Scott Lang and Sam
Wilson are actually pretty good friends
not only does Sam Wilson recommend
Ant-Man to fight on their side in Civil
War but when Scott wanted more
information on Sonny Birch he reached
out to his favorite avenger connection
Sam Wilson to get the low down scoop on
sunny in this story their friendship
though a little hesitant is endearing
and they both have non-super power
abilities they both love Captain America
and they both recognize the importance
of family all of this is mentioned in
Ant-Man and the WASP the hero's journey
on Spotify and come on at the end of the
day Sam Wilson and Scott Lang being best
friends is genuinely not surprising
sorry not sorry Bucky